a few days after uploading my original
dubai video in august 2021 i was sitting
at my computer unsuspecting suddenly an
email came through
i'm warning you
not knowing what to make of it i
foolishly opened it
dear adam you've just posted a latest
video about dubai and i've forwarded it
to the authorities and to makto himself
as i am a known friend of his listen
what you just posted will get you in big
[ __ ] i'm telling you yes your check and
you probably don't give a [ __ ] but you
don't know who you're messing with plus
you haven't even lived in dubai and
can't prove your argument not just that
you're promoting hatred and bad image to
a multi-million dollar gdp country and
not just a country a kingdom people have
the power here and just imagine what
would they do to you i recommend taking
that video down immediately do it now
before the authorities get to
this email was no joke
clearly the author meant business
knowing that from now on every word can
be used against me i proceeded with my
response nice this is the navy seal copy
pasta but unionically jokes aside you
might want to reconsider this email
according to paragraph 8 section 20 of
european union common law threatening an
eu citizen with state force of a third
country carries severe consequences it
likely even qualifies for european
commission article 5 section 11 about
advocating for or threatening with state
terrorism against an eu citizen now i
found your channel in the meantime you
don't show your face as far as i could
see but your relatives do
also you film the neighborhood you live
slash used to live in it won't be hard
to identify who you are i'm considering
forwarding this email and all the
information i gathered about you to eu
consular generals and embassies in dubai
and abu dhabi together with an official
request for investigation my video might
raise some eyebrows in the emirates but
the eu is their most important trading
partner and so the eu's word carries a
lot of weight
and unfortunately for you the eu takes
threats against the citizens very
very seriously you're not the first one
to go to prison for such a thing nor
will you be the last
i don't want to do this but your email
leaves me no choice
after clicking send i sat back and
waited
how will the dubai sheik's personal
friend react to my message
dude i'm a kid and hey i'm just giving
you advice i'm not telling you my dude
i'm just reporting because you're hating
the country and it's not nice to say
thanks for that and don't get me wrong
you wanted to say bad things about the
uae and i did nothing wrong i don't see
anything i just said be careful of her
what you say jk let me know her i'm just
looking for another brother just kidding
at this point i just responded with the
following
and this is your lesson to stop sending
stupid [ __ ] to people you don't know i
will not report you to the eu
authorities but if you send me stuff
like this again i'll be in touch with
ambassador donna ludina
he then sent me another panicked message
and then asked if i gained by any chance
i'm sorry but when the eu authorities
come for you minecraft will not save you
that was the last time i've heard from
sheik maktoum's personal friend
what became of this fearless warrior of
the emirate
that is something we might never know
[Music]